[Music]
elon musk's mission with tesla
is no secret accelerate the world's
transition into sustainable energy by
making his electric vehicles super
affordable to do that
the gigafactory will have to produce 500
000 cars a year
and for that he is going to need an
incredibly efficient production chain
and a factory the size of a few
football fields at least tesla currently
has four
gigafactories around the world the
nevada base which is 1.9 million square
feet
and still only 30 percent complete the
new york base which is focused on solar
energy more than vehicles
shanghai which is the newest one and
handles the final assembly of the model
and production of the model y and the
berlin base
which is still not operational but will
be soon
the tesla gigafactory was made for the
purpose of upping production to help
drive down costs and efficiency is
everything in this game
so today we're going to look at how
tesla cars are made in these giant
factories
welcome back to our channel if you
haven't already make sure you hit that
subscribe button
and ring the bell so you never miss a
video from us
there's no doubt that tesla's assembly
line is the best in the world
and it is supported by hundreds of
robots and thousands of human workers
the gigafactories have 160 robots which
by the way
are all named after x-men characters
many of the model s's unique components
including the battery packs modules and
drive units
are manufactured in-house the plant has
a high level of integration
compared with other modern car assembly
plants so most processes take place
right here
this includes most of the stamping and
machining painting
and also some coding even the design
engineers work in the factory itself
rather than in a separate facility but
let's start from the start
shall we there are a few components made
from raw materials in a typical auto
plant which has been the case since
2016.
around 60 of the car's parts are sourced
from north america while the remaining
is sourced from japan the tesla model s
starts with a coil of raw aluminum which
is cut
stamped and joined to create a complete
vehicle all within one facility it
starts with
uncoiling the coils in a blanking
machine that flattens the metal
and cuts it into fat pieces called
blanks and additional cutting is done by
lasers
the total weight at this stage comes to
only 410
pounds a robot then transfers these
blanks to the tandem press lines
where the sheets are stamped into the
various panels of the cars
the shuler smg hydraulic stamping press
line is the largest in north america
and the sixth largest in the world and
uses up to 11 000 ton
force to form the body panels the upper
section applies 1400 tons of downward
force
and the lower section 113 tons the blank
aluminum sheet
is stretched over the lower draw die and
the openings are cut with robots
transferring the panels between
processes this is all carried out by
giant robots
whirring constantly the humans come in
around this time to inspect every single
panel and ensure correct pressing the
parts are then
all stacked in frames and stored the
machines press one part every six
seconds and create five thousand parts
per day
meanwhile the batteries are being
manufactured in a different place in the
gigafactory altogether
the battery for the model s contains
18650 lithium-ion battery cells placed
in 16 modules
each module contains six groups of 74
cells
wired in parallel and wired in series
within the module
unlike every other electric car
manufacturer using specialized large
format lithium-ion cells
teslas use commodity cells which are
commonly found in laptops and phones
their liquid cooled battery pack uses an
intumescent gel
to help in fire proofing and even in
distribution of heat
and no we aren't even close to the
assembly stage yet
we haven't even discussed the motors the
alternating current induction motor is
constructed in-house
and it begins when a robot unwinds over
half a mile of copper wire per motor it
then pulls the wire into a stack
since a tesla motor has three phases it
requires three coils of copper a worker
will then lengthen
and straighten each bundle of wire each
bundle is insulated in a plastic sleeve
to prevent them from touching one
another
and the ends are snipped to the correct
length then lugs are added
and crimped to form attachment points
for the motor's three phases
a specialized sewing machine then binds
the coils together
and the increased tightness increases
the efficiency of the engine
the main components of the motor are the
stator and rotor
at this stage the stator is encased in a
two-part epoxy resin to help evenly
distribute the motor's heat
the stator is now complete and inserted
into a heated metal case
and left to cool the worker uses a
hoisting system to insert the rotor in
the stator
thus completing the construction of the
tesla motor
coming to other drive unit components
the worker installs the differential
and other sections of the gearbox and
attaches them using bolts
then the tests begin an air leak test
for starters to check for any
microscopic holes
failed seals and other defects that
could cause issues in the long run
after that a three-phase tri-pole power
inverter is installed on top of the
motor to convert direct current from the
battery to the alternating current for
the motor's use
the power inverter is made from metal
oxide semiconductor
or moss power transistors then the motor
undergoes a few more tests to ensure
proper functioning before being moved to
the general assembly area where it meets
the body
and the battery the body of the car is
raised and the drive unit
is installed into the rear axle assembly
this unit sends power directly to the
wheels without a drive shaft after that
the battery pack which weighs almost
1200 pounds
is raised into the car using a lift
batteries and tesla cars sit at the base
of the vehicle to offer strength and
lower chances of the car toppling over
in an accident
then a titanium plate is put out over
the battery pack which protects it in a
high-speed collision
and from road debris at any typical
automotive plant of any other brand
the car is essentially on a train that
never stops as components keep getting
added to it in the tesla gigafactory
however the model s
is on a smart car which moves around the
plant as required
workers stopped the smart car to inspect
different elements throughout the
process
tesla's 160 robots work alongside 3 000
human workers and they all have very
specific jobs
sometimes however a robot can carry out
different tasks by switching its tooling
after just 13 years in the game that
kind of innovation
proves tesla is running full speed ahead
and there's no
telling what their impact will be in 20
or 50 years
tesla is also making its fifth
gigafactory in texas and according to
musk it will be an ecological paradise
the site sits on 2500 acres of land and
the goal of the factory is to produce
model 3 and model y
cars for easier distribution in eastern
america
it's also going to be the main factory
for the highly anticipated tesla cyber
truck
and the tesla semi some larger buildings
have already gone up on the campus
and tesla is even posting job
opportunities for the site it is also
rumored that there will be a gigafactory
in
asia outside of china another one in the
united kingdom
and one in india these are all
unconfirmed but if tesla continues at
the rate they're going we might well
need those mini gigafactories to meet
demands
all in all tesla is continuing to expand
its global footprint with hopes to
provide the world with affordable
electric cars
solar panels and clean energy if you're
planning to do your bit for the
environment and switch to evs
make sure you order them now though at
the moment production isn't at the scale
of legacy car makers
and each tesla car is made to order
which means it's a two to three month
wait for delivery
even if the actual assembly process
takes no more than five days
so would you ever buy a tesla let us
know in the comments below if you
enjoyed the video make sure you hit the
like button
and check out the simply tech channel
for more thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time